dude got announced today don't let that
bother you your boy
your boy's going to miami next week
working floyd uh
logan paul really i leave thursday for
miami is that right
you stoked pretty stoked no way i don't
know what they do how long how when is
june june uh the first sunday
it's fights on a sunday so wayne's
because it's a
entertainment fight exhibition fight so
they don't have to do the mandatory sat
day before
right so the logan uh floyd wayne's on
friday that's kind of like a
celebration weigh-in and then there's
actual real boxing
like organized like commission boxing
they weigh in
to the standard saturday and then the
fights on sunday i'm very i'll tell you
what i'm very excited about
what the two things i'm one thing i'm
worried about is floyd's hands i don't
know how brittle they are
so i don't know how hard he's gonna be
hitting uh mr logan paul
but what i'm very interested in i'm
interested to know if if floyd is going
to make
logan pay for the sins of his brother
ooh
over his brother taking his hat i wonder
yeah yeah i want to know
and the other thing i want to know is if
i want to see if logan paul can actually
put a glove on floyd mayweather now keep
you in mind he's 44
and i would remind you that a guy named
manny pacquiao
didn't touch him that's what i was
saying he made him miss he made canelo
miss he's made everybody miss
my only caveat to that you're assuming
the floyd mayweather is in the same
mental space that he was in
when he fought man yes i am but how good
yes i am yeah see i don't i don't think
he's been the same mental space as when
he fought conor
i think he's even looking at this as
more as more of like i want to punish
this joke no
oh more of a joke yeah than really
connor's connor's a much better boxer
by far but he didn't even entertain that
really like
i know from close sources he really
didn't train for that bubba i bet he
didn't did he
no no i'm sure he didn't he didn't train
conor no
you're talking a different language it's
like if you speak fluent spanish
and i learned it for two weeks and tried
talking to you like dude come on
there's no different like there's no
there's no air it's not even the same
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i love where logan paul's at on it
because he was on first take and
you know max is on there and uh uh
stephen a smith is on there
and he's sometimes human smith drives me
nuts but whatever but he goes hey look
he goes logan you got to realize like
these real
boxing aficionados and like people like
legend of the space
you know they're a little upset that
you're getting this opportunity to fight
floyd like you haven't done anything to
deserve it he goes
i never said i did yeah he he was but
who wouldn't take this opportunity
because also you guys are forgetting
floyd hit me up i do i wasn't chasing
floyd he hit me up because he knows how
much we can make find a guy like me
he's like so you know for me it's a
win-win he goes if i lose yeah
everyone's killing you
he goes but if i win because what
happens what happens to the box
by the way i mean you can say whatever
you want about the the paul brothers
they get in the ring they do they do
training work their ass i mean
you know they're both athletic kids and
jake um uh
this what's with showtime now jake's
with showtime he's he's trying to be a
real boxer yeah
that takes balls i don't care what
anybody says like and oh by the way he
makes
how much money is he making crazy amount
crazy so so
what i from what i've seen he's actually
getting in there and boxing with the
real dudes and getting him taken he's
tuned up yeah but then taking
some weight show time then is he gonna
get like yeah legit
you're not gonna see lamar odom or some
[ __ ] in there they're gonna
like but he might get like a mike perry
or you know they're not going to toss
some of the [ __ ] wolves yeah yeah
obviously you're sure as [ __ ] not
getting
you know these youtubers like it's
showtime yeah like showtime really don't
play that game
showtime wanted like a regular
production like
that you know they wanted morrow and you
know they're they're old-school
old heads and don't you think and i told
him i said that's not the way to do this
right he's a big boy what is he
who heavyweight who uh jake 185 what
yeah yeah he'll be four weight classes
heavier than floyd don't you think don't
know that matter no no no
but don't you think it's smart for him
to fight and see what they do
don't you think it's smart for him to
fight mma guys who are
like like guys like mike perry and and
and yeah
because because boxing is different it's
just different distance right mid
distance
but he's eventually gonna have to face a
real body yeah but everyone complaining
is that's not the the path right now
yeah like mike perry would be great
there's
some other guys that could i i think
what about um
the guy who always amazes me at his
striking is
i'd love to see nate diaz get to be
honest i think nate's got
so much more experience nate boxes all
of them have way more experience yeah
but no i mean
nate boxes boxes with boxers and has
been doing that mid-distancing forever
for sure but my thing is is he going to
beat nate no
but i just think that level if you want
to really see where you're at
oh yeah you know that pressure and then
nate this is what i want for nate you'd
make so much money a lot of money
so i want guys to have the opportunity
to make so much money and have that
platform nick or nate diaz would be
great